[Music]
[Music]
so most of my colleagues in cognitive
neuroscience believe that our senses
were shaped by natural selection that we
evolved and that the selection pressures
are such that those creatures that saw
the world more accurately had a
competitive advantage over those who saw
less accurately and so they were more
likely to pass on their genes that coded
for the accurate perceptions and so the
result is after thousands of generations
we're the offspring of those who saw the
world more accurately and so we can be
pretty confident that when I see tables
and chairs and the Sun and the moon and
so forth that I'm seeing reality as it
is
no one believes we see all of reality of
course we only see the parts that we
need to see but that the parts that we
do see we're seeing truthfully and so
I've looked at that from the point of
view of the mathematics of evolution the
evolutionary game theory and we can
actually run simulations to see what
happens and we can prove theorems and
we've done both and the bottom line is
that the probability if our senses
evolved in we're shaped by natural
selection the probability that we see
reality as it is is zero and that that
means not simply that I've you know I
don't quite see the shape of a chair
correctly or I don't quite see the
colors correctly it's it's much deeper
than that the problem is that the very
language of space and time and physical
objects is the wrong language to
describe objective reality you could not
frame a true description of the world in
that language it's not possible so it's
not that we get it off a little bit here
or there
it's that this whole thing is just the
wrong framework for describing reality
so that seems so counterintuitive and so
out there that I think metaphor is
needed to help understand how it might
be working and the metaphor I like is
the user interface on you know the
desktop interface on
computer if you're writing an email and
the icon for that email is blue and
rectangular and in the middle of your
screen does that mean that the email
itself the file in your computer is blue
rectangular and in the middle of the
computer well of course not anybody who
thought that misunderstands the point of
the desktop interface it's not there to
show you the truth in this metaphor the
truth be the circuits and the voltages
and magnetic fields all that complexity
most of us don't want to know about that
that's really nasty if you had to toggle
voltages to craft an email your friends
wouldn't hear from you it's just too
hard
so what evolution has done for us is its
evolved us sensory systems touch smell
sight sound hearing all of this all
these sensory interfaces as a user
interface that the purpose is to hide
reality completely to hide really just
like your desktop interface on your
computer is there to hide the circuits
you don't want to know about the
circuits and yet it allows you to
control the circuits right by using
icons and dragging them and clicking and
so forth you can control the reality
without knowing anything at all about it
and that's what evolution did
3-dimensional space is your desktop it's
a three dimensional desktop not just a
two-dimensional desktop and the icons
are three-dimensional not just flat
they're what we call physical objects so
tables and chairs and spoons and forks
these are icons that evolution is shaped
to tell us about Fitness payoffs and how
to get them so it's all about Fitness
even space itself is about fitness the
distance between me and an apple ten
meters away versus ten miles away is
telling me that it will cost me fewer
calories to get the Apple ten meters
away it'll cost me a lot of calories to
get the Apple ten miles away probably I
should go for the Apple that's ten
meters away so even space itself is
representing Fitness payoffs and fitness
costs and so so evolution in short has
shaped us with a user interface that
hides reality on purpose or you know
purposes in quotes the evolution is just
a process but
the effect of the part of the process is
really to hide reality so that so that
you're not distracted by it and you can
you you can control reality without
actually knowing what it is and so the
theory of evolution that I mentioned
that says we don't see reality as it is
has a really strange consequence it
means that when I see a physical object
like an apple effectively I'm creating
that Apple as a data structure in my
interface much like if I'm in a virtual
reality and I'm have a headset on and
every time I turn over here I will see
something I'm rendering that in real
time I see an Apple as I go over here
I'm no longer rendering I you know the
Apple is gone but as soon as I turn over
there yet I will again create a
three-dimensional Apple so I'm saying
this doesn't just happen in virtual
reality it happens in everyday life I
look over here I see an apple I'm
literally creating that data structure
because now I'm effectively an Apple as
a description of Fitness payoffs and how
to get them it's all about fitness
that's the key thing evolution is all
about fitness but that means that the
objects don't exist as pre-existing
things when I see an apple we like to
think well I'm that's because there
really is an apple and I'm saying no no
there's some other reality out there but
just like the blue icon on your desktop
doesn't resemble the true file the Apple
does not resemble anything and objective
reality it's an abstract data structure
that's just telling you how to act to
get fitness payoffs here's the kicker
when you look inside your brain inside
your skull and you see a brain that's
also just a data structure that you're
creating neurons are just data
structures they don't exist and this is
the weird stuff I don't have a brain
when no one looks and some of my
colleagues would say yeah I agree with
that you don't have a brain but but they
have the point of this is that that we
create any physical object that we see
in the moment that we see it and so
neurons don't exist when they're not
perceived therefore neurons could not be
the source of our conscious experience
in fact space-time itself is just your
data structure so the idea that
space-time exists and has existed for
fourteen billion years has a
pre-existing stage on which the drama of
life plays out is also deeply wrong
space-time itself is just a data
structure that we create so what is
reality this long answer to your
question but the answer is I don't know
but I'm trying to come up with a reality
that would allow me to solve this hard
problem of consciousness so if the brain
is just a symbol that we create when we
look you know trying to understand how
consciousness is related to it if I
start with during which consciousness is
fundamental and I have to do it
scientifically say what do I mean
precisely by a consciousness with
mathematical precision and and I have
this theory of that called conscious
agents in which conscious agents
interact it's like a the proposal is
that reality is a vast social network
it's a heat like a Twitter verse or
Facebook so is a big social network of
conscious agents that's the reality
they're not in space and time they're
their dis consciousness is interacting
with each other as they interact they
are passing experiences back and forth
and there's it's an infinite
Twitterverse yeah an infinite set of
consciousness is out there in this in
this big social universe social you know
yeah social networking University and
any single conscious agent in that
network would be overwhelmed trying to
understand all of it like if you were
trying to understand Twitter there's
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
users billions of tweets how are you
going to try to understand what's going
on in the Twitterverse well you can't
but what you can do is you can use
visualization tools suppose I have a
visualization tool that compresses that
all down shows you what's trending in
this city and what's trending over there
so you can press it all down and maybe
into something that you can see through
a headset so that you can actually
here's the Twitterverse and in London
here's the Twitterverse and Edinboro and
so forth and here's what's what's going
on here's what's trending then you could
sort of visualize it that's what
evolution did for us
the reality is this big vast social
network of interacting conscious agents
each individual agent would be
overwhelmed because it's infinite social
network and so what we call the physical
world just is our visualization tool
that's what we have so we've mistaken so
this is all a big visualization tool
space-time and physical objects are the
way we visualize our interaction with
this vast universe via social networking
at university I'll give you one concrete
example to really bring it home when you
look at your face in the mirror all you
see literally is skin hair and eyes but
what you know firsthand that you don't
see in the mirror is the whole universe
of your conscious experiences your hopes
your desires your aspirations your
headache the the sound of music that
you're hearing right now your love of
music all the stuff that's you that's
it's almost infinitely complicated
universe of conscious experiences all we
can see is this and compared to the best
universe of our conscious experience
this is extremely simple if I smile you
can guess that I'm happy I'm feeling
some conscious experience but a smile
does not resemble happiness it's just it
signifies it and so think about it this
way your face my face
the face that you're creating when you
look at me is your portal into my
conscious experiences the face that I
see when I look at you is my portal into
your conscious experience it's a portal
but it's very very small portal most of
you is left out you can't see it in the
mirror I can't see it from outside when
I look at my cat the portal is even
worse I mean I can figure out maybe the
cat likes this kind of food and doesn't
like that likes it when I pet but now
I've petted it too much no I need to
stop when I look at an ant my interface
is really giving up I have no insight
into the conscious agents in this vast
network that I'm interacting with and
when I get to what I call a rock my
interface has given up but it has to
give up I have a finite interface I'm
dealing with an infinite social network
of course the interface that's
purpose is to throw most of the
information away to simplify things and
allow me to negotiate with this universe
of you know interacting conscious agents
without getting overwhelmed and so of
course at some point it's not gonna look
conscious anymore at all my interface is
giving up what we've done is we've
mistaken unnecessary limitation of our
interface as a and we've taken it to be
an insight into the fundamental
fundamental nature of reality we've
assumed it reality fundamentally is
unconscious because at the simplest
level our interface that is necessarily
unconscious so physicalism is a very
simple mistake this assumption that
space time and matter are fundamental is
a simple mistake we've mistaken a limit
of our interface as an insight into
objective reality but it's it we can we
can break out of it it's it's it's a
natural mistake but we could break out
of it
[Music]
well we've tended to think that most
people imagine that the world is
something out there and it's divided
into bits and the puzzle of life is to
work out what those bits are and indeed
the puzzle for human knowledge has been
to try and work out what those bits are
and I think that we've in the 20th
century discovered that we can't
actually arrive at an account of what is
out there because we are embedded in a
perspective and there are an indefinite
number of perspectives and so I take the
rather surprising starting point that
let's consider the world not as being
something that's divided into bits but
is something other it's some unspecified
other and that what we do is we close
this and what I call this unspecified
other openness to avoid us thinking that
it's something in particular and we
close the openness of the world into our
ideas of thoughts and things and
properties and so forth and the what we
do in in the closing of the openness of
the world is we give ourselves ways of
intervening but at the same time we sort
of cut ourselves off from the openness
so it's a sort of two-way exercise that
we need closures in order to intervene
but they also in a way take us further
away from openness so you take an
example of this bottle you might say
well it's a it's a bottle and by doing
that it means that we can do things with
it you can ask me what sort of bottle it
is you can ask me to pass the bottle you
can say what's in it you can say where
was it manufactured you ask all sorts of
things about what it is but you might
say you might describe it not as a
bottle at all you might describe it as a
weapon
in which case its wall isn't an
effective weapon does it does it does it
do the damage that you intended
- you might say it's environmental
disaster in which case you say well just
how dangerous is it it's an
environmental disaster you know where
does it fall on the scale if you were a
physicist you might describe it in terms
of its molecular structure so all of
these different ways of holding this bit
of the world are closures I would say
they're ways of closing openness and the
stuff the openness this whatever is
there is all of these things it's like
the potential to hold them in this way
so I think we have to give up the idea
that there's there are bits out there
that we name and instead thinking of the
world as being open that we closed on
those closures have value and they can
be refined and they can get better but
they're not somehow an ultimate
description there are a way of holding
the world rather than being how it
ultimately is what is the point in the
issue of trying to understand the world
because we can refine our closures once
we've chosen one we can ask all sorts of
questions about it so as I was saying if
we if we hold something in a particular
way we could say well what sort of
example of this is what sort of bottle
is this is what sort of new person this
is whatever the closure is so we we
refine those closures and those closures
then enable us to do more so the attempt
to deepen our closures and make them
achieve the outcome that were we what we
want from them - to enable us to use
that frame that vocabulary in a way
that's valuable is is immensely
immensely powerful it's just that I
think that we shouldn't think that
they are an ultimate description of the
world they're a way of holding it and
there's an indefinite number of other
ways of holding it which have different
qualities and different values and I
think also the other thing is that
closures never the same as openness is
the different sort of stuff I think it's
a category mistake to think they're the
same sort of thing that they're just
different sorts of things so if you look
closely at whatever the closure is it
will never be as the world is so you can
always find ways in which your closure
fails they're always going to fail it's
never going to be a code word with that
oh yeah we've got we've sorted it now it
was always an infinite gap between
closure and openness but trying to
refine them and make them more effective
for whatever purpose we want for is an
immensely valuable exercise just as is
finding the ways in which they don't
look so I think the idea that we close
off the world in these ways by a would
sound familiar to a lot of people but
could you explain what openness is
because that is a that seems like a huge
idea yes so you have to provide some
sense I'm not I'm a not I'm a non
realist so I'm a critic of the idea that
our ideas reflect things that are out
there in the world so the question is
what's the alternative to realism and I
would describe myself therefore as a
post realist or a non realist and that's
because I can't tell you what is going
on other as it worth and realism I can't
say well it's like this because if I
could then I would be my you know I
would be a realist again I would be
telling you that's what it is out there
but it seems to me that our experiences
are not descriptions of the world
they're not like mirrors of the world
they are a causal response to the world
so when your eye responds to the world
and neurone fires you know one of the
hundred million neurons whatever fires
well that neuron is responding in one
particular way to everything that's out
there so it takes all of the openness of
the world and it does one thing and we
hold the world as that one thing so it
will it amino in fact of course we hold
all a whole load of neurons together as
say a patch of blue and all of those
neurons won't be firing in exactly the
way it same way and they won't be blip
but what we do is we hold things as us
as a single thing the world's nothing to
do with that thing it's not a
description
it's a closure so when I when I said
describe the world was being used the
word openness I am would be saying that
it's an unspecified other and I'm not
saying that there's no there's nothing
out in it's all in our heads there's
plenty of stuff ER there but it's not
differentiated it's not you know it's
language that differentiates things into
objects and things and properties and
you know all of that sort of stuff but
what's out there
is a different sort of thing and the way
of trying to give an idea of what it's
like to say well let's just imagine that
it's an unspecified other on a way of
thinking about it's a thinking it is
being open and full of potential and we
we close that potential with our
closures but we can't if I could tell
you what openness was then I wouldn't be
a non realist I would be a realist again
and I think we just have to give up the
idea that we can say as it were how it
ultimately is in favor of this this
account which enables I think a way of
understanding why it is we have
different perspectives why people can
have such radically different views and
all think they're right and
and indeed 2.2 perhaps you know other
ways that we could interact so that we
can try and stand in the place of other
perspectives rather than thinking that
there's a correct answer and somebody's
got it wrong somebody's got it right I
race operate with very small amounts of
information we don't have access to all
of our physical environment through our
brains we just sample small parts of it
and we make up a whole lot of the rest
so based on this very sparse information
we create this grand simulation of
reality but a lot of that is made up in
a sense even if it has a physical
correlate out there nevertheless our
brain is constructing it a couple of
examples the insights of objects if I
think about solid objects say the back
of my phone is a rectangle I can see the
edges and I can see the inside but
neurons in the early stages of my visual
system they're only responding to the
edges it is only later on along the
visual pathway that neurons take this
information from the edges and use it to
make up but the inside must look like we
call this filling in and it applies to a
whole lot of our vision it applies to
our cognitive processes too
we fill in a lot of cognitive gaps
another example from a personal
standpoint is our perception of 3d so to
be sure we believe that there is a third
dimension out in the world but our
perception of 3d from a visual
perspective is a brain construct our
perception of 3d is fundamentally a
brain construct our retinas are
basically two flat surfaces that give us
only to the information and it is based
on these 2d information
later on our visual brain is able to
make up this third dimension which again
even if it matches reality it's a brain
construct our brains are constantly
trying to make sense of the world we're
trying to connect causes and effects
make inferences which may be real may be
illusory and so we come up with stories
we tell each other stories about how
things work we tell ourselves stories
about our own behavior in fact research
suggests that we interpret our own
actions much as we do the actions of
other people we don't think necessarily
and then we act but we act and then we
try to come up with a good explanation
for why we behave the way with it I
don't think that we need to be
frightened of illusions I think we
should generally embrace illusions
illusions have evolved with us they're
part and parcel of who we are their
fundamental to our neural processes it
is interesting that the visual system
which is of our sensory systems the one
that takes up more brain space will have
over 2,000 brain areas dedicated partly
or wholly to the processing of visual
information so our vision is very
refined compared to most of our other
senses and yet we have a lot more
illusions in vision than in the other
senses which to me it's a one good
argument for how illusions are not
something to get rid of but something
that are part of our neural function
they're not a bug they're a feature and
the same can be said of other kinds of
cognitive illusions for instance in
estimation of probabilities it turns out
that people who are healthy have healthy
brains and good mental health in
estimation of probabilities people who
are in good men
they'll Health turns out that they're a
lot more optimistic than clinically
depressed people who are actually
realists they have a much more accurate
estimation of what the probabilities of
success are for instance in a game of
chance
the phenomenon of illusion is quite
interesting because it tells you
something about how our perceptual work
our perceptual systems work and what
happens if they don't work and what
happens if they don't work is that you
get a variety of different experiences
that we would consider to be illusory
like hallucination and when you see
marriages and dreams and so on and they
seem to project or convey a different
kind of reality or a different kind of
type of reality experience and now the
question is of course is that as real as
the reality of the waking world is a
different kind of reality or is it just
something that looks like reality but
isn't really alright so this kind of
phenomenon which you can which you can
investigate quite precisely by using
empirical means raises these very deep
philosophical questions about the nature
of the world in the nature of our
perceptual relations with the world so
to that extent illusions are very
interesting way and very very I think a
good example of getting into a
discussion of these fairly fundamental
questions and so do you have an example
of one such illusion which gets to these
fundamental questions well I mean you'd
start up with a very everyday experience
like dreaming right so everybody dreams
most people dream every night and you
are when you're dreaming you're
transported into a world which is very
very different from the from your waking
world you probably still think you are
you so there's some kind of continuity
but it's already very difficult to say
you know what kind of time you are in
you know are you you're obviously not
usually you don't dream that you are
that it's night when you're night right
she's obviously in a different kind of
time you might be in a space that's
completely different from your usual
surroundings so you have this experience
of being immersed into a completely
different world which once you are in
the dream
looks exactly as real as all of this
stuff here yeah and now the question is
if you are so completely taken in by
that in this situation why are you more
convinced that when you are in the
waking world as I think I'm right now
why are you more convinced that you are
actually really in touch with things
that are out there like a really exist
in space-time whereas in a dream where
it exactly feels the same but we would
think no in that case this is all just
something cooked up by your mind or
cooked up by your brain now so to that
extent just a very everyday phenomenon
like dreaming gets you into into those
kinds of questions and this is why
philosophical traditions from all around
the world have focused on that I thought
that was a really interesting
theoretical problem and so you see these
those philosophical problems rather than
scientific problems which might be able
to explain these issues of illusion yeah
I think these two these two issues work
together right of course there is the
scientific question you know what
actually happens when we're dreaming
what kind of neurological processes are
involved how do they differ from the
kind of neurological processes that are
involved in the drape in the in the
waking world and so on so this is what's
tough science can tell us a lot about
yeah but what the the next question that
we want to ask then and that is where
they where the scientific question stops
is what is actually at the other end of
the representation what is being
represented right and that is something
which is a question that asks something
about what is that the other side of
empirical means that it's not something
you can investigate by empirical means
because the empirical means only take
you so far yeah so to that extent the
the the scientific questions have to end
at a certain point and at that point you
really have to start with a theoretical
reflections about the scientific results
in order to get any further and so you
said that those opposition's are all
over the world of sort of dealt with
these
or like the phenomena of dreaming for
instance why has your work focused on
philosophically and how is how they
dealt with this why you went wait long
for this philosophy that's right yeah
hmm is there something we can draw on to
help explain these illusions well the
the I mean the phenomenon of dreaming
became very important in specific parts
or branches of Buddhist philosophy where
in general the whole idea that the the
world is in some way illusionary it was
became a major intellectual focus and
different different Indian thinkers in
particular try two different ways of
trying to explain that and try to make
sense of what that means and one way of
trying to explain it was was saying look
the entire world is mental in substance
right so when we look at things so I see
this tent over there and there's
actually not and there's not an external
object out there let's rather what I see
here is some some construction or
concatenation of mental things of ideas
or different moments of consciousness or
something like that right so what
they've been trying to do there was
trying to develop in a theory of the
external world that didn't assume that
the fundamental entities or the
fundamental constituents of reality are
bits of matter but bits of mind right so
that extent it's it's quite an
interesting way of trying to come up
with a theory that is the complete
inverse of we normally what we normally
think is the best way of explaining the
world namely first of all explaining the
material a bit and then see how mind
gives rise to that but they were trying
to do was the other way around they
started with the idea of consciousness
in mind is a primitive and then they try
to come up with an idea of how the
material word could arise from that and
where are your own thoughts on this do
you think mine comes before matter on
that
comes before mind ah well that's a good
question I think well if you if you
answer the question either way you'll
have to assume that there is some level
of reality that is fundamental and
everything comes from that right so we
have a kind of foundationalist picture
now I think that is probably is probably
not a satisfactory way of thinking it in
the end because what you end up with is
a set of entities such that the
dependence variation goes both ways
right so the material stuff determines
mental stuff and it make the staff
determines material stuff so it goes C
it goes both ways round in which case
you'll end up with a position where you
have no fundamental theory or you have
no rock bottom ontology to explain it
all so you end up with this kind of
coherent is picture where everything
depends on some other things but there
are no completely independent things
yeah so I think that is the most the the
most satisfactory philosophical way of
thinking about it
last book before Zed was a field guide
to reality which is a book about this
idea of a field guide to reality a sort
of perfect manual for fixing existential
angst what would happen if we had a
perfect book that would solve all our
existential dilemmas you know why am i
here what's the meaning of life and
you'd have this single absolute book and
like so many fictional concepts it can't
really exist it's absurd but I thought
I'd have an eraser who was among other
people trying to find it because
ostensibly it did exist but even in my
parallel reality it's been lost and so
she's on this quest so that was a first
person in the race it because I wanted
to be in her mind trying to fathom this
quite a strange idea of this perfect
book that keeps eluding her but would
you define your work as
philosophical novel yeah I think it's
definitely fiction I'm really interested
in an idea of the philosophical novel as
a thing and I mean kami said that all
novelists all the novelists he sort of
liked were philosophers because they
were asking as soon as you think about a
reality I think about creating a reality
you start asking well what is a reality
you know what what does it comprised of
so as book as demonstrates you can take
a philosophical concept and you can make
a fictional scenario out of it so you
can say for example what if there was an
infinite place where every part of a
person's life could be represented every
possible reality and so you can do that
in fiction because you can do anything
in fiction and so you can advance
philosophical ideas and sort of almost
put them into practice in invented world
and so tell us about that
what's it so said I was thinking for a
long time about how to write about the
digital age and this huge revolution
that we've all lived through the last 20
years where societies completely changed
through technology and we've just
completely radically altered the way we
spend our time and our perceptions of
reality because we exist online in this
strange semi incorporeal state which is
the cyber world and so so much has
changed also we've had the advent of
kind of all-seeing technologies that can
overlook us to a great extent through
all these devices that we have our
phones and our computers and even our
TVs so I want to write something about
this and I had this idea that there's a
huge amount of prediction that goes on
now there's an idea that not only do all
these kind of companies take data and
use it to
control advertising and you know
advertise more specifically to people
there's also a further layer of that
where they try to nod just towards the
things that we're expected to like so
it's not enough just to predict it you
try and urge the behavior towards this
as well I thought that was really
interesting I thought what does that say
about humans and freewill and you know
are you really able to execute freewill
if your kind of environment and reality
change around you in line with the
notion of what you want and did the
process of writing it leave you feeling
hopeful about the ability to have free
will
yes and I thought it's really
interesting when you look at algorithms
I mean algorithms are a kind of to-do
list for a computer you know if this
happens this if this and so and I was
really interested in bork as as I do of
the garden of forking paths' this story
he wrote in the forties where he said if
you're gonna really write a realist
novel of a person's life
you'd have to include all the possible
realities that they might ever live in
all the Forks in the path you know all
the paths they might take and so the
novel would be infinite and also
unreadable and unrightable and I thought
that was such an interesting idea in
terms of anticipation prediction of it
even one human life actually there's so
much that's unexpected about everything
we do as humans we're not easily
predictable in so many interesting ways
and people surprised us all the time
that we know and so I thought that kind
of interesting idea of trying to almost
trying to marshal humans through a
perfect system but actually humans being
the unexpected elements in that system I
thought that was such an interesting
philosophical tension to explore in a
novel
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you